JENNA TAYLOR: Today, I'm
super excited to welcome
Liza Gershman to Google.
Welcome.
LIZA GERSHMAN:
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's your
first time here with us?
LIZA GERSHMAN: It's
my first time here,
and I'm really honored to be.
I've always wanted
to come to Google,
so I'm very excited and
honored that you've all
taken time out of
your really busy days
to come be here and
learn about Cuba
and eat amazing food that
the team has prepared.
I'm really thankful to
everybody on the Google staff,
and also to my
awesome publicist,
Andrea Burnett,
who organized this.
And then also Kirk Dye,
who is my right hand
on all my projects.
So thank you guys so much for
being here and for having me.
And it really is an
honor to be at Google.
You're the first stop
on the book tour,
so this is very exciting.
The book is official
today right now.
So yes, Amazon released
it today officially,
and my publisher
sent out a blast.
So this is really fun to have
Google be the very first stop,
so thank you.
JENNA TAYLOR: Well, what
better place to start a fun
adventure than Google land?
LIZA GERSHMAN: Exactly.
JENNA TAYLOR: Fantastic.
So you're not technically
a chef, right?
LIZA GERSHMAN: Right.
JENNA TAYLOR: Neither
am I, thank God.
You're a photographer.
So anybody who's
seen the book, it's
all about these
beautiful photos.
So tell us a little bit about
how that became a career
writing cookbooks.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Sure.
Actually, it's a
bit of a long story.
I'm a photographer and a
writer, and I'm a great eater.
Aren't we all great eaters?
JENNA TAYLOR: Amen to that one.
LIZA GERSHMAN: People always ask
me-- this is my 12th cookbook.
And people ask me, how
do you write cookbooks
when you don't cook?
And the simple answer is,
I am great at research.
People give me their recipes.
I'm very curious,
and I love to eat.
Just because I don't spend
time in the kitchen--
I save that for the
experts who won't
burn things and ruin things.
But I am great at eating, I'm
great at making reservations,
and this book is
not just a cookbook.
It's a food book.
And it's something so much
different from a cookbook.
It is a connection with Cuba.
It's about a place.
It's about people.
It's interviews with
restaurant owners.
And it's recipes from people
in their home kitchens in Cuba
and people in their
restaurants and friends--
people who have become my dear
friends over the last 13 years
that I've been going to Cuba.
So it's that.
It's the story of the island.
It talks a little bit
about the politics of food.
Food is political
anywhere you are.
Cuba food is especially
particularly political.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah, I thought
it was a fascinating glimpse
into kind of an opaque
culture for many of us.
So how did you start
going down to Cuba?
What was your first reason?
And then you kept going back.
LIZA GERSHMAN: I
did keep going back.
So it's one of the few places
that I have gone repetitively.
I really believe
life is so short,
and there's so
many places to see.
You need to keep
experiencing and exploring.
But Cuba and I have a thing.
We are in love.
And the first time
I went was 2003,
and I went with Global Exchange.
It was an educational
exchange tour,
and it was the only way to go.
When I went, there
were no other tourists.
There was my tour group,
and at that moment in time,
that was it.
And we had to stay
with our guide.
There were 13 of us.
He had a script.
By the end of the week, we could
very much tell it was a script.
And he broke it a little bit and
said like, oh, I'll tell you,
but I might get in trouble.
And it was just a very
different time and place then.
It really was right before 2003.
It was many years before
the Cuban government decided
that individuals could
own their own businesses,
so it was very much the
old ideology-- the old way
of thinking in Cuba.
And I am really grateful
that I got to see that.
So even then, just my first
moment off the airplane,
I felt like I was home.
And if you've had
that experience where
you've gone somewhere
other than your home,
and you've had such a strong
emotional connection--
it's the sense and the
sounds and the visuals,
and it just feels like
this is part of me already.
It's like already built
into my DNA somehow,
even though as far as I
know, I am not at all Cuban.
And so that was it.
I had this trip,
and I was really
intrigued and interested.
And anywhere that you
say nobody's going--
I went.
Sign me up.
How do I get there?
So for me and Cuba,
that's why I went then.
I had just finished
graduate school.
I have a master's degree
in English and American
literature.
And I took a year to
travel afterwards,
because I didn't know what I
was doing with my master's.
I wasn't there to teach.
JENNA TAYLOR: Join the club.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Right.
I was there as a personal
indulging moment,
where I wanted to talk about
literature in this really dorky
way that nobody else wanted to.
And so I went to grad school.
JENNA TAYLOR: I was an art
history major, so I'm with you.
LIZA GERSHMAN: And you guys
probably all understand, too.
There's probably something
that every single person
in this room is an expert
at or really curious about
that your general friends do
not want to know about, right?
So that was me and books, and
that was then me and Cuba.
And so I went, and I loved it.
And then I didn't go
back for a long time.
There wasn't an
easy way to do it.
And I wanted to make
sure I went legally,
and that I was doing
things on the up and up.
And I was curious about so
many places in the world.
So I've been really
fortunate and blessed
to go to 51 countries.
I'll be impressed by
that when I get to 100.
Until then, to me, it's nothing.
But I've been really
fortunate to travel a lot,
and so I didn't go to
Cuba for a long time.
And then I was at
a talk in New York.
Many things in my life happened
really serendipitously--
all the good things do.
I was at a talk in New
York I had been invited to.
And the author was
speaking about a book
she had just done on Cuba--
Damon Seeley.
Hi.
Damon's my best friend from high
school, so that's really nice.
JENNA TAYLOR: Welcome.
LIZA GERSHMAN: He's a Googler.
JENNA TAYLOR: I love
the Google connections.
Welcome.
LIZA GERSHMAN: So I was
at a talk in New York,
and I didn't know the author
was speaking about Cuba.
And she spoke about Cuba, and
I went up to her afterwards.
And I said, oh, my gosh.
I've been to Cuba.
I loved going.
I would love to take you
out to coffee or a drink
and talk more.
And she said, oh, sure.
Here's my contact information.
And you know, like most
people, she assumed
I would never follow up.
But then the next day, I was
on her phone, on her phone.
I'm here.
When can we go to lunch?
When can we go to coffee?
So anyway, we met.
And she said, as
it turns out, I'm
writing a book about
Cuban food, and we
need a food photographer.
And I said, oh, I've
done 11 cookbooks.
Maybe I could photograph yours?
And she said, great.
The publisher I'm working
with is called Skyhorse.
And I said, oh, I've done
eight cookbooks with Skyhorse.
That's really a
no-brainer for them.
JENNA TAYLOR: Small world.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Right?
Small world.
Serendipity.
Serendipity, right?
I don't know if you
believe in signs or not.
I'm kind of superstitious.
And when things are
that in my face,
I'm going to pay attention.
So even if you're just
not-- coincidence,
whatever you want to call it.
I listen.
So she and I went and
met with the publisher.
And long story
short, she did not
work out for the project for
the publisher, ultimately.
And they said, Liza,
we know you can write.
Will you please just
write this book?
And so I said, sure.
But I now have to go back
and do all this research.
And they said, OK.
We'll get on it, right?
JENNA TAYLOR: Aw, shucks.
I got to go to Cuba.
Darn it.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Exactly.
So that led to a three-year true
love affair with the island.
Last year, I spent
more nights in Cuba
than I did in San Francisco.
I have incredible
friendships there.
I'm friends with artists and
painters, musicians, writers,
and also I'm friends with all
these economists and engineers.
It's such a fascinating place.
Your taxi driver in Cuba likely
used to be a chemical engineer
or likely used to
be a physicist.
And the person that's making
your sandwich most likely
is an economist and
has a master's degree.
It's just the way
their culture is,
and I'll explain all
that in a minute.
If you can remind me,
please, I'll talk about that.
An average Cuban
salary is $25 a month.
And if you have a high--
JENNA TAYLOR: A month?
LIZA GERSHMAN: A month.
And if you have a high
paying professional job,
it's about $45.
If you work in the tourism
industry-- yeah, exactly.
So if you're the top
surgeon in Cuba--
well, if you're the very
top surgeon in Cuba,
you're working on the
Castros, and you're
having bonus this way.
But if you're guy number 15,
you are making $45 a month,
and that's not
enough to do what you
need to be doing for living
in a comfortable way.
So then you come, and you
get involved with tourism.
And if you're a driver,
you can make $20 for a ride
from point A to point
B. Or you can make food
at a restaurant, a normal
tourism restaurant--
or just not a touristic
place, but a restaurant
that somebody in this
room might go to-- a meal
might be $25, $30.
So right there, the benefits
are so high for Cubans
to be involved in
the tourism industry.
And out of all of the countries
I've been to on the planet,
they are by far the most
entrepreneurial people
I have ever met
in my entire life.
They are scrappy and inventive.
They're like MacGyver.
They will make a car out
of this thing, this thing,
and that thing.
And you have no idea how that
works, but suddenly it's a car.
And it's also cool looking.
JENNA TAYLOR: It sounds
like that there's no choice.
You have to be that way.
LIZA GERSHMAN:
There's no choice.
It's out of necessity.
JENNA TAYLOR:
Traditional norms are not
going to get you
where you need to be.
LIZA GERSHMAN: They're not.
And people really think
out of the box in Cuba,
because the box doesn't work
or it doesn't exist, right?
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah, I was
really interested in it.
You talk about food as really
being more than just food.
It's woven into their culture.
It's just part of every
aspect of life there.
Talk a little bit about
that and what that means.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Absolutely.
So I think we're so fortunate,
particularly all of us
in this room.
I'm assuming
incorrectly most likely.
I can eat every day, right?
It might not always
be at Gary Danko,
but I can eat every single day.
JENNA TAYLOR: Any one of you
with a badge can eat every day.
And I bet that you do
more than once a day.
We're super lucky.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Exactly.
So anybody in Cuba who
grew up during the '90s
or was alive during the '90s
went through this time period
they call the "special period."
And the special period was the
least special period of Cuba.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's like
a branding exercise
more than anything
it sounds like.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Yes.
So the special period was
when the USSR at the time
pulled out, and Cuba
was left with literally
no international support.
And they were fending
for themselves.
And Cuba is an island,
so one would assume,
oh, they're eating fish all day.
They're growing vegetables,
fruits, no big deal.
They can absolutely
sustain themselves.
But it's just not woven
into their culture that way.
And because of a number of
governmental regulations,
people are not allowed to fish
because they can't have boats.
People are not allowed to grow
their own produce unless they
live in the countryside.
You can only live
in the countryside
if you were born
in the countryside.
Or if you don't have
that opportunity
to have been born
in the countryside,
you can purchase
fruits and vegetables.
But if you're a farmer, you have
to give a certain percentage
to the government,
and then you can
maintain the rest for yourself
and sell a very small portion.
Well, when you
take the vegetables
from the farm in
the countryside,
and you get on the highway
to come to Havana where
the biggest population is
to sell the vegetables,
there's probably a roadblock.
There's probably some
kind of checkpoint,
and something will happen.
So a lot of the people
in Havana are not
getting the amount of
vegetables they need.
Not only that, but if you
imagine a country that
has the most chemical-free
fertile soil in the world
and the most pristine
living reef on the world,
and you're not allowed
to have a boat,
you can't effectively
fish for the reef.
It's not in your culture
to swim because it's
an island where people have
spent decades escaping.
So people don't learn to swim.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's a
little bit like Alcatraz.
LIZA GERSHMAN: It's a
So for every single thing I
have to say that is a concern,
there are so many positives
that outweigh the concerns.
JENNA TAYLOR: Sure, sure.
But there's real challenges.
LIZA GERSHMAN: There are real
challenges for Cuban people.
If we just talk about
San Francisco right now,
I can tell you how I've seen
it changed in my lifetime.
There are no homeless
people in Cuba.
There's no gun violence.
There's nobody who's
addicted to drugs
because they don't have drugs.
They don't have guns.
Every single person
has an education.
Every single person on
the island can read.
There is no AIDS--
very little cases of STDs.
There are so many
remarkable things,
and there are constraints.
So it's a complicated place.
Whenever I bring people to
Cuba, which I do all the time,
people always come with some
kind of a preconceived notion.
They want to-- is
this right or wrong?
And I find that
particularly my friends who
are in their 50s or older come
down, and they have an idea,
and they want an answer.
Is this a good or bad place?
It's not.
It's a complicated place, right?
It's a complicated place.
But there are so many
wonderful things.
So food is changing.
And food is, I think in
any culture, a great way
to really see what's happening.
Who are they trading with?
Where are they getting
influences from?
How are they learning
and expanding?
What are they doing
to be innovative?
You can really see
that, because the thing
that every single person on
the planet does is has to eat.
JENNA TAYLOR: We got to eat.
We got to eat.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Every person
on the planet eats, right?
JENNA TAYLOR: Food brings
us all together, right?
It's a great unifier.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Right.
Not everybody plays music.
Not everybody sings.
Not everybody can do math.
Not everybody goes running.
But every single
person has to eat,
so you can see so much about
a culture in their food.
And the food in Cuba has really
changed over the last few years
with the growth of tourism.
And in 2010, the Cuban
government allowed Cubans--
for the first time
since the embargo--
for the first time to
open their own businesses.
And if you're going to
open your own business,
you want to open it in
the tourism sector, right?
Because that's the way you're
going to make the most money.
So the way to do
that-- many people
opened up restaurants
in their own homes.
So the paladares
initially were--
and it was fun to go to them.
It was one room, and you'd go,
and you sit at the one table
in the room.
And the mother or the
grandmother would cook for you,
and you would eat the meal.
And then you'd pay some money.
Now, with the growth
of tourism, paladares
have become more like
actual restaurants.
And Havana in particular
is getting some restaurants
that are as high end
as things you would
see in San Francisco, which
is really tremendous to see
that change over
the last five years.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah,
that's exciting.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Yeah.
It's very exciting for people.
There's just so much
potential and promise
for the Cuban people in
that, because more people
are being employed outside
of governmental jobs.
So they're being able
to have higher salaries.
JENNA TAYLOR: I was
really interested
in the limited
number of ingredients
that repeat in the book--
obviously diversely
expressed, but talk
a little bit about why that is.
We're dealing with a
small subset of things.
LIZA GERSHMAN: So back
to what I was speaking
about earlier is part of
the complicated nature
of the island is when you have
an embargo for so many years,
you're not getting seeds
from other populations.
You're not trading with people.
And so Cuba in itself
grows very few things.
Their soil's
absolutely wonderful,
and they basically grow--
they grow plantains, bananas,
a lot of root vegetables,
pineapple.
But they're not growing
avocados, for example.
They're not growing
heirloom tomatoes.
They're not growing mushrooms.
They're not growing olives.
All of the things
that we kind of take
for granted that we think--
JENNA TAYLOR: Californians
are all like, [GASP]..
LIZA GERSHMAN: No avocados,
which is bad for me.
JENNA TAYLOR: No
heirloom tomatoes?
What are you talking about?
LIZA GERSHMAN: So
that's something.
When I was there
a few trips ago--
maybe it was last year-- there
was a group of German farmers
who had been there.
And they were all in their
late 50s and early 60s.
And these were a
group of 10 men who
had all-- when the
wall came down,
they were responsible
for seeding and supplying
all of the farming culture.
So they came to Cuba to look
and see if that was possible.
And one guy was the
potato guy, and one guy
was the tomato guy, right?
Each person had their specialty.
And at the end of the trip--
which is when I met them
at the end of their trip--
they said, it's so complicated.
It's muy complicado, right?
It's so complicated
and frustrating.
And they've already
been through that.
They've already been through
their own food revolution.
It wasn't for them.
JENNA TAYLOR: You're
coming from that background
to say it's complicated.
It's pretty complicated.
LIZA GERSHMAN: So when
people are coming with me
and they ask what to
pack, I always say,
if you can't get it
camping, you probably
can't get it in Cuba, which
is a great rule of thumb.
And it helps you really imagine.
Can I get deodorant
when I'm camping?
No.
Is there a store where
I can buy lemonade?
No.
Is there a place where
I can get jalapenos?
No.
So I always say, if you
can't get it camping,
you probably cannot
buy it in Cuba.
And also, the government
has brokered deals
with companies for one product.
So let's say you go
into a grocery store.
The shelves will
be sort of stocked,
but they have one brand.
So they might have four rows
of this one brand of oil.
In Mill Valley, how many of you
have been to the kombucha aisle
in Mill Valley at Whole Foods?
It's the whole wall.
And it's, I don't know,
100 kinds of kombucha.
But that's not the
way it is in Cuba.
You have one product for every
single thing that you have.
And luxury-- if you go
into the five star hotels--
which they're really
not five star to us--
if you go into those hotels,
the shops in the hotels
are selling Suave as
the fancy shampoo.
And so really, we're
blessed in so many ways.
But just our access to
products extends to food.
Also, Cubans are
on a ration system.
So the Cuban government
automatically--
just if you're born,
you get an education.
You get health care.
You get housing.
It might not be the most ideal,
but you still get housing.
It's a complicated system
of who do you know,
and how do you know them
depending on the hierarchy
of what you get.
But you're given a ration book.
And the ration book covers your
food for 20 days of the month.
And what it covers is
not enough for protein,
and it's not enough for--
it's very minimal and basic.
But a lot of Cubans,
that's what they exist on.
And unless you have this extra
job, or you work in tourism,
or you're doing
multiple things--
you're renting out an
Airbnb room in your house--
that's what you're living on.
But everybody has something,
it's just not quite enough.
It's never quite enough.
JENNA TAYLOR: Fascinating.
Chef, are you about ready
to kick off our demo?
Chef Christie is going to
actually prepare something
delicious for all of us.
What are we making today?
LIZA GERSHMAN: We're
making a chicken dish.
We're making the mojo chicken.
JENNA TAYLOR: Mojo chicken?
LIZA GERSHMAN: Yes.
JENNA TAYLOR: All right.
Well, a little secret I'll
share with you-- the first step
of the mojo chicken involves
the loudest blender on earth,
so we're going to focus
on chef for just a minute.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Before
we do the blender,
can you raise your hand
if you've been to Cuba?
I'd love to know who in
the room has been to Cuba.
Awesome.
Great.
That's more than I anticipated.
JENNA TAYLOR: Does Miami count?
LIZA GERSHMAN: It does not.
It's very Cuban, but
it's a world apart.
JENNA TAYLOR: Right, yeah.
It's Cuba US.
LIZA GERSHMAN: So
the question was,
in Miami and on the
east coast, there's
so much great Cuban food,
and what are the differences?
And primarily, the difference
is access to ingredients.
So Cuban chefs in Cuba are
so limited on ingredients.
And if somebody like
myself, let's say,
wanted to bring sun
dried tomatoes in a bag
and give it to a chef friend,
that chef friend-- if somebody
from the government came
into their restaurant
and saw that they had sun
dried tomatoes on their menu
or in a meal, that
person could go to jail.
So it's not worth
the risk for them.
So here's a story that Kirk
reminded me on the drive
down here that you guys
might want to hear about.
Beef is totally
prohibited in Cuba.
It is only reserved
for tourists.
If you kill a cow, the
penalty is a lifetime in jail.
JENNA TAYLOR: A
lifetime in jail?
LIZA GERSHMAN: A
lifetime in jail.
And if you murder
somebody, it's 10 years--
a person, even a person.
JENNA TAYLOR:
That's interesting.
LIZA GERSHMAN: So if you're
caught with beef illegally,
the penalty is very high, even
if you haven't killed the cow.
So I have a friend whose husband
just spent four years in jail
and got out this
week, thankfully,
because he was driving
on the highway,
and there was a
man that he knew.
Cuba's really small, so
everybody sort of knows
everybody, or you're a friend
of a friend of a friend.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's like Google.
LIZA GERSHMAN: It's
like Google, sure.
No, it's much smaller.
It's 11 million people.
I always say to
people, Havana is
the size of Union Square and the
Tenderloin, and then that's it.
That's where the highest
concentration of the population
is.
So if you're in Union
Square, you run into your--
raise your hand if you've
ever been downtown and seen
someone you know.
Right, so it's like that.
OK.
So he saw somebody he knew on
the highway who needed a ride.
Everybody's always
needing a ride
because most Cubans
don't own a car.
Because a car in Cuba--
a beat up car could be $15,000.
A new car from China could be
$250,000, $75,000 for something
that's from the '90s, so
most Cubans don't own a car.
So this man needed a
ride, and the other man
didn't check in the bag.
If you needed a ride,
I would not say,
what's in your backpack, right?
So the other man had four
pounds of beef in the bag,
and they were stopped
at a checkpoint.
And my friend's husband was
told by the police, well,
you're the driver.
You must have known
what was going on.
You're going to prison.
So for four years,
he's been in prison.
And he just got out
this week, thankfully.
JENNA TAYLOR: Well, treat
that steak with a little bit
more respect, huh?
What do you think, Chef?
Fire this thing up.
Everybody bear with
us for one second.
I promise it'll be
delicious and worth it.
Come on, chef.
I thought that was
going to be way louder.
There we go.
What is a bathtub
pig, and why is that
a good thing and not
something that terrifies me?
LIZA GERSHMAN: So during the
special period in particular,
when people had even
less access to food,
people were really surviving
then on maybe a piece of bread
in the morning and a glass
of water with sugar in it.
They were eating terrible
things like pizza dough,
and then they would put
condoms on top of the dough
and melt that in
place of cheese.
It was a very dire--
JENNA TAYLOR: Plastic?
LIZA GERSHMAN: Plastic.
The '90's-- that was an
incredibly dire time in Cuba
where there were no
resources for food.
Yet here, it's an island.
They could fish, but it's
very complicated, right?
So anyway, there were
no resources for food
that the government was willing
to allow the people to have.
And so people would make a trade
with somebody and get a piglet.
And then they would
bring it to their home,
because it was
illegal to do this.
And they would raise
it in the bathtub,
and then they
would slaughter it.
And then to make
money and have food
to feed their
family for the year,
they would sell it off to
their neighbors discretely,
and they would keep
some for themselves.
So those are bathtub pigs.
JENNA TAYLOR: So this
was a common practice
that there's bathtubs
full of pigs.
LIZA GERSHMAN: So every
Cuban has a workaround
for everything, right?
So the fix is, all right,
we're not allowed to eat pork,
but I need protein.
I'm going to go get a pig
and raise it in my bathtub.
Cubans are so genius this way.
Everything has a workaround.
They have a black market
that the government just
looks the other way about.
It even has a website,
and it's called Revolico.
And if you need something,
you go to Revolico.
Let's say I'm a painter.
Right now, there is
an incredible shortage
of artistic supplies.
There's no canvas anymore.
You can't get white paint.
So all of my friends
who are painters
are having this
extreme freak out
about not being
able to make art.
So naturally when I come
down, I'm bringing supplies.
But they are making--
they're inventive.
So a friend of mine,
he found an article
that was about how the
Egyptians made paint,
so he's been making paint.
He's been making paint the way
the Chinese were making paint.
So I might not do that,
because I'm a lazy American--
not that all Americans are lazy,
but I am probably not going
to--
JENNA TAYLOR: Just
used to having
what you should need and want.
LIZA GERSHMAN: I'm used to being
able to go to a paint store.
And if I can't, then I'll
probably give up and move on
to another project.
But a Cuban's not
going to give up.
They have an idea, and
they're sticking with the idea
and making the idea happen.
And it's just part
of their culture,
so that's really a remarkable
thing about their culture
that I love.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's amazing.
Absolutely.
LIZA GERSHMAN: It's a
huge inspiration for me
to be there and see how
inventive people are,
and their determination
for things, and for change,
and their allegiance
to family and friends,
and the social network
that they've developed
that is community-based.
Because when you don't have
the internet in your home,
and you don't have your phone
and you need information,
the only way to get
it is to ask somebody.
And so it's a gossip society.
Everything happens
through word of mouth.
So if you have a question about
something, or you want to--
is it going to rain today?
How do they know?
Is there a meteorologist
they can get a hold of?
No.
But when I'm in
Cuba, sometimes I'll
text somebody in
America and say,
what's the weather forecast?
And they're always wrong.
And then I ask my
friend's mother in Cuba,
and she'll say, oh,
it's raining in an hour.
They just know.
JENNA TAYLOR: That's fantastic.
I think we could do
with a little bit more
of that kind of
thing in our culture.
LIZA GERSHMAN: I agree.
JENNA TAYLOR: Chef, you want
to talk about a little bit what
you're doing over here?
CHRISTIE: So I tossed some yams.
And I always like to point
out that a lot of recipes
will say, put them in a
bowl before you toss them.
It's no reason to dirty a bowl.
Just go ahead and toss
them on the sheet pans.
JENNA TAYLOR: Dirty the sheet
you're going to dirty anyway.
I like your style.
CHRISTIE: I always
like less dishes.
So just a little bit of olive
oil, salt, some seasoning,
and we're going to
pop these in the oven.
And then for the
mojo dish, we're
serving them with
the yams, but also
with some peppers and onions.
So I'm just sauteing.
I'm going to put
some wine in there.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Can
everybody hear Christie?
CHRISTIE: Can you guys hear me?
I'm going to put some wine
in here, reduce it a little.
And then we have the chicken.
I made the mojo sauce.
I put it onto the whole chicken.
We've had one
already marinating,
so we're just going to go
ahead and put that in there,
pop it in the oven,
and let it go.
JENNA TAYLOR: Smells
amazing already.
I'm super excited.
Just scooch us out
of your way whenever.
CHRISTIE: I'm just going
to pop these in here.
JENNA TAYLOR:
Surprise, surprise.
I can see the finished
product in there already.
It's TV magic.
We'll pretend.
It's OK.
So I also heard it's similar
to lots of big cities.
There's Little Italy.
How is that possible within
the tiny Union Square footprint
of Havana that they've got
these other culinary influences
coming to life?
LIZA GERSHMAN: So the
only sub-neighborhood
they have that
would be like that
is they have a Chinatown, which
surprised me the first time
I went to Cuba.
But they had a huge
Chinese influence
of people coming from
China to build things.
And then there's been
a big Italian influence
in the cuisine.
You can always
find pizza or pasta
on any menu pretty much,
which is also surprising,
but it's delicious.
And they have
tomatoes, they just
don't have heirloom tomatoes.
So they have the right
ingredients for that cuisine.
I'm always telling them, you've
got the right ingredients
for tacos.
Let's make some.
JENNA TAYLOR: You're going
to bring tacos to Cuba.
LIZA GERSHMAN: I'm going to
bring tacos to Cuba, exactly.
I'm always like, let's
have a burrito today.
JENNA TAYLOR: Well, you're
from California, right?
LIZA GERSHMAN: Exactly.
JENNA TAYLOR: So that's what
California girls should do.
We propagate tacos
around the world.
I love it.
Does anybody have any
questions while we're
waiting for all this
magic to cook down?
You think of Cuban food,
you think of all this spice
and seasoning and
these strong flavors,
but they don't have
a lot of ingredients.
So are we being influenced by
the American interpretation
of Cuban food, or how do they
really bring that to life?
LIZA GERSHMAN: Sure.
It's a little bit of both.
There are some dishes, like
the dish we're eating today.
The mojo sauce is really
prolific in Cuban cuisine,
and it's very
flavorful, very spicy.
The national dish of
Cuba is ropa vieja,
and that is the most
delicious shredded beef,
if they can get it,
otherwise they use pork.
And that's in a tomato sauce
that's really wonderful.
So they do have some
spices, absolutely.
A lot of what we think about
is an American interpretation,
just like Mexican food here.
If you go to Oaxaca,
it's not the same, right?
Similar.
The culture is spicy, in a way.
It's not hot in flavor.
Cubans in general don't
like hot temperatured food.
They're very
resistant to pepper.
They don't understand.
Why would you put
that on your food?
It's so hot.
They don't have a lot of hot
peppers in their cuisine,
but they do have a
lot of rich garlics
and onions and things like that.
So you get a lot of
flavor from that.
JENNA TAYLOR: So if beef isn't
available to regular people,
is there a big
divergence between what
tourists eat in Cuba and
what Cubans eat in Cuba?
LIZA GERSHMAN: Absolutely.
100%.
Tourists have a much richer--
and I talk about this a lot
in my book about
how these recipes--
so many Cubans will never
be able to experience
some of these dishes.
If you work in tourism, then on
occasion you have enough money.
Or maybe you have a friend
who works in a restaurant.
If you work in a restaurant,
sometimes you order--
there's a saying
in Cuba about it.
Where you order
more than what you
think you're going to sell so
you can give it to your staff,
and they can take it home.
JENNA TAYLOR: Family meal, yeah.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Family
meal, exactly, exactly.
So lobster, for example,
is another thing
that's forbidden to anybody
who's not a tourist.
But if it's a restaurant,
maybe the lobster guy
had 10 lobsters today.
You're only selling two.
You might buy them all
so everybody can eat.
Cubans take care of
each other very much,
which is another
really remarkable part
of their culture.
So there is a huge difference,
and it's changing a little bit.
As tourism dollars are coming,
people are getting more money.
And everyone has somebody in the
family that works in tourism,
so it's trickle down.
People are always
working for their family
and for their friends
and supporting them.
The traditional meal you might
eat if you don't have access,
you definitely eat a diet--
a lot of beans and rice.
But it's mostly rice-heavy
with very few beans.
And then eggs-- you'd have a
lot of eggs, a lot of bread,
and maybe some chicken
if you can get it.
That's the most common--
and then very little
vegetables and fruit.
JENNA TAYLOR: Interesting
LIZA GERSHMAN: But
it's all in the book.
And you can read in detail
about it, particularly
if you read the introduction.
That's where you
can really learn
about all the changes in food
over the last few decades.
JENNA TAYLOR: Did you have
a question over there?
OK.
So this is a
fascinating question,
and I want to hear it.
So one, can you talk a little
bit about distribution network,
knowing there's a lack
of road infrastructure
and maybe electricity for
refrigeration and all that?
And then secondarily, how do
those people who are running
restaurants get their food?
LIZA GERSHMAN: It's a very
complicated situation.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's
muy complicado.
We keep going back to that.
LIZA GERSHMAN: It's
muy complicado.
I always have to be
thoughtful about what I say,
because I'm mindful
of my love of Cuba
and wanting to go there.
So I have to be very considerate
about how I phrase things.
It is a place with a
lot of complicated rules
that are ever changing and a
complicated infrastructure.
The roads are not the best.
And having a car or a
truck traveling from a farm
and to the city--
they just don't have the
equipment to do that, really.
So the flow is limited,
and the supply is limited.
And the restaurants operate
through the black market
almost entirely.
JENNA TAYLOR: So even though
the travel industry is approved,
you still have to go black
market to get your ingredients.
LIZA GERSHMAN: So government-run
hotels and restaurants have
very terrible ingredients, and
the service is something to--
JENNA TAYLOR: I will
say, maybe not the best.
I haven't been, but
I heard from someone
that it was not the best.
LIZA GERSHMAN: So
restaurants that
are now becoming more Western, I
guess you'd say, or higher end.
I don't know how we
want to phrase that.
They are absolutely forced to
use the black market every day,
all day.
And there's just a
turn the other head.
But if you had dried
cranberries on your salad,
we can't overlook that.
But if you're getting lobster,
well, we can overlook that.
It's a big "don't ask,
don't tell" kind of culture.
JENNA TAYLOR: Well, I love
many things about your book,
but food to me is a perfect
inroad into any culture,
like you said.
It's the great unifier.
But I think that the images that
you pair with these recipes,
I think, really do bring to
life, again, a place where
fewer of us than normal
really have had access to go.
It's fascinating, and I love
hearing your inside scoop on
really what it's like
and how it's changing.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Absolutely.
And it's also this wonderful
place where you can be--
where you are forced
to be-- completely
disconnected from the internet
and from your cell phone
and from all the other
companies in the world
that we do this with.
People there are talking.
They're having conversations.
They're thinking about things.
They're discussing the things
they're thinking about in a way
that a lot of my friends
have stopped doing, frankly.
And sometimes we'll get to
Cuba, and I'll think, oh, yeah,
I haven't had a conversation
with you in two years.
We're just hanging
out in the same room.
JENNA TAYLOR: And now
we're going to chat.
LIZA GERSHMAN: And now
Now we're stuck
together for seven hours
with no distractions.
JENNA TAYLOR: That's
great, though.
Yeah, that's beautiful.
LIZA GERSHMAN: So it's amazing.
And family is really important.
People end up living
with their families
for much of their life.
It's really unusual
to be a Cuban
and then go have your own
apartment or your own house,
so community is very strong.
And I think there's
a lot of joy in that.
So what I noticed beyond their
remarkability of invention
and creation in
Cubans, I also notice--
there's just a
palpable sense of joy.
For people who have such limited
options, they're so joyful.
The culture is joyful and
alive and vibrant and musical,
and everybody dances or sings.
You're required to spend
two years in art studying.
That was really
important to Fidel,
and so everybody has to do that.
And I think that's
a real benefit--
to learn something about an art
really brings joy to your life.
And you can see that
in their culture.
It's incredible the
spirit people have,
and they're so resilient.
In most families,
someone has left,
and so people have this
internal pain and struggle.
But they are so positive
about everything.
I have friends where
three of their siblings
don't live in Cuba,
but they just still
have this zest and love for
life that I find is remarkable.
And people aren't
self-medicating.
They're not taking prescription
pills to go to sleep,
and they're not
drinking too much.
In a country if you make $25
a month, and a bottle of rum
is $7, you're probably not
spending all of your money
on that bottle of rum.
So I've really never seen--
of course, there have
to be some drunk Cubans.
That's not part of the culture.
My friends have a drink,
and that's it, right?
And that's just part of it.
They don't understand
the concept.
JENNA TAYLOR: Well,
excess is not a thing
that really exists there.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Excess
is a privilege.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah,
that's pretty powerful.
LIZA GERSHMAN: It is.
So there's a lot of
joy in that culture,
despite the lack of things.
JENNA TAYLOR: Constraints.
LIZA GERSHMAN:
Constraints, absolutely.
JENNA TAYLOR: Did somebody
over here have a question?
I love that question.
So how does having a camera
change your relationship there?
It sometimes might give you
access, sometimes it might not.
What has that been like?
LIZA GERSHMAN: I find
that there are many times
I don't use my camera.
On my last trip, I
didn't take any pictures.
I'm there so often
that now I go to--
my last trip, one of my
friends, it was her birthday.
Another friend had an
art gallery opening,
so I went to see those things.
And the only pictures I took
were on my cell phone of like,
hey, we're here
together-- the selfies.
So sometimes I'm bringing my
camera, and sometimes I'm not.
People are very receptive
to being photographed.
I find that cultural norms in
countries really dictate that.
So some countries I go to
and every single person
wants their picture taken by me.
And I'm like, you'll
never see this.
Are you sure?
When I went to China,
every person near me
wanted me to take their picture
and wanted to be in my picture.
Guatemala-- nobody wanted
their picture taken.
Because in Mayan culture,
they believe that you're
stealing their soul.
Most Cubans enjoy having
their picture taken.
And then, of course, there
should be an exchange.
I come from much more
privilege than they do.
And so if I take someone's
photo, I'm giving them a meal,
or I'm giving them some money,
or I'm bringing them something.
I think that's really
important to me--
to always be constantly giving
back to everybody in Cuba.
So when I go down, for
example, I have clothes there.
I don't bring a
suitcase any more.
But I bring two suitcases
that are gigantic,
and I check them, because
I'm bringing gifts
for all the people I know.
And then I bring extra
gifts for other people.
So I bring guitar strings
for musician friends.
I bring tattoo needles
for a tattoo friend.
I bring canvas and paint
for another friend.
My lovely housekeeper
that I'm always with--
I bring her new bras,
because you can't get them.
I bring her lotions, and I
bring her earrings and things.
She just loves
that kind of stuff.
So it just depends on who
I'm visiting at the time.
But I'm always
bringing something,
because I'm a guest
still, no matter what,
even though they
all say I'm Cubano.
I'm a guest.
And I have so much, and I'm
so grateful for what I have.
And I know that anything
that we can give to anyone
there is more than they have.
JENNA TAYLOR: That's beautiful.
I love that.
Chef?
CHRISTIE: I'm going to
actually take this--
JENNA TAYLOR: This is what
we've all been waiting for.
LIZA GERSHMAN:
This looks amazing.
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh my gosh.
LIZA GERSHMAN: You guys,
this looks delicious.
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my gosh, chef.
Wow.
Yum, yum, yum, yum.
LIZA GERSHMAN: It's beautiful.
Beautiful.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's gorgeous.
LIZA GERSHMAN: You guys
are really lucky that you
get to eat like this every day.
It's amazing.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah, it's true.
I'm not going to lie.
You got a question there?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
I had a question.
What was the reaction of your
Cuban friends to the book?
JENNA TAYLOR: What did your
Cuban friends think of book?
LIZA GERSHMAN: So the book--
it was a 2 and 1/2 year
project, so they all--
where's the book?
How's the book?
And I finally got
to bring the book.
I got back from my last
trip four days ago,
and I finally got to bring
the book on the last trip.
And Cubans-- they're not
accustomed to receiving gifts.
It's just not part of
the culture, right?
When you don't have,
you don't give.
So you give a gift to somebody,
and they say, oh, thank you.
And you think, oh, I guess
you're not really excited.
And then a while later, you
realize how excited they are.
But it's not like
the kid at Christmas
unwrapping the paper
screaming, which
is kind of the response I
like when I give a gift.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's also just
not part of their culture.
LIZA GERSHMAN: It's not part
of their culture, right?
JENNA TAYLOR: I also like
that response, by the way.
LIZA GERSHMAN: But it's not.
I kept telling Kirk I would
give somebody my book,
and they would
say, oh, thank you.
And then they'd maybe go
walk away or whatever.
Maybe it was a restaurant, and
I'd sit down and have a meal.
And then I'd get up
to use the restroom.
And I'd look over,
and then I would
realize the entire staff
was out of the kitchen,
and they were looking at
every page of the book.
And that was such an honor.
JENNA TAYLOR: That's beautiful.
LIZA GERSHMAN: That to me
was really worth every moment
that I wanted to give
up on this project.
When you're writing
a book, there
are a lot of times where
you just want to be done
and over it, and you're
ready to say, I quit.
People really were grateful.
And to see them genuinely--
they weren't taking it
in front of me, and I think
that's what made it better.
They were doing it, but it
wasn't show her we like this.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's more genuine.
LIZA GERSHMAN:
It's more genuine.
And it was really
every single time.
It was incredible.
Yeah, it was great.
People are really pleased.
And I put so many friends in it.
JENNA TAYLOR: I was going say,
are your friends in there?
I love it.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Yeah,
my friends are in it.
So it's like a yearbook
of my friends, right?
This is my friend
Enrique, and he
owns La Guarida, the most
famous restaurant in Cuba.
In the front, we've
got two of my drivers
and one of my friends
that's a guide.
It's like a yearbook of
my Cuban life basically.
These are my friends.
And it's really fun, you know?
JENNA TAYLOR: What a privilege.
LIZA GERSHMAN: It's great.
My friend and his
dog are in the back.
And in the back of the book,
I have a suggested itinerary--
my favorite things to do.
I have a section that's how to
stock your pantry to prepare
all of these easy dishes.
There's a section,
spruce up your Spanish--
just a couple of fun words.
There's a list of
Cuba's top restaurants,
Rob, and bars, and the addresses
of them so you guys can--
JENNA TAYLOR: There you go.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Yeah, exactly.
So it's not just a
cookbook, you know?
It's a lot of things.
It's really kind
of a guide to Cuba,
and there are always more.
And then people who register
online on my website,
you'll get emailed
some other tips
about-- is it OK to say that?
You'll get registered some other
information about Cuba that's
not in the book,
so that's fun, too.
JENNA TAYLOR: Very cool.
So what are your favorite
recipes from the book?
LIZA GERSHMAN: Oh, ropa vieja
is my favorite dish in Cuba.
It's the national dish of
Cuba, and it's so flavorful.
It's a low simmer.
It's like a slow cooker
recipe, basically.
It's delicious.
I love rice and beans.
I'm always going to
be a fan of that.
Plantains and this
chicken is good.
All the drink
recipes are amazing.
The cocktails-- obviously,
it's a place that--
it's lively.
Rum-- let's have a cocktail
and listen to music.
Just one.
Maybe two.
JENNA TAYLOR: So ropa vieja
is primarily a beef dish, so--
LIZA GERSHMAN: So
Cubans improvise.
That's the motto of Cuba--
improvise.
And so they'll use whatever they
have, and that's usually pork.
Pork is the most easy
protein for a Cuban to get.
JENNA TAYLOR: So a pork
ropa vieja is very Cuban.
LIZA GERSHMAN: In the
book, the recipe's
for beef, just because I
know we're American, right?
And where's the beef here?
JENNA TAYLOR: Anybody else?
Questions?
AUDIENCE: Is there a difference
in the food from the north
part of the island, like
Havana compared to Santiago?
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
Does the food change on
different parts of the island?
LIZA GERSHMAN: That's
such a great question.
So my favorite part of the
island is "the Orient,"
and that is the area
that is the countryside.
And the food there comes
farm-to-table in the most
original, authentic way
farm-to-table exists.
And there are a lot of
restaurants that you can go
to that are farms, and you eat.
They bring everything
from the farm,
so you're eating straight
out of the garden.
And I would spend my whole life
just in Viales if I could.
If I had the internet, I
would live there permanently.
JENNA TAYLOR: You're
at Google, so we're
happy that you said that.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Can you make
this happen for me, please?
Great, you're working on it.
JENNA TAYLOR: Cuban internet.
Send them Loon
Balloons over to Cuba.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Get ready
for me to be moving then.
JENNA TAYLOR: I love it.
Well, I know that we're getting
some delicious bites plated up
for you guys.
Is there a couple
of last questions?
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
favorite Cuban restaurants?
JENNA TAYLOR: Favorite Cuban
restaurants here or in Cuba?
In the US.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Oh, yeah.
My favorite Cuban restaurant in
San Francisco is Media Noche.
It's down in the Mission.
And they're partnering with
me on a number of events
coming up, so it's really fun.
Yeah, I love them.
The food is fantastic.
They have a lot of integrity
in their ingredients
and their recipes.
It's owned by two women
who are our peers.
I love to support women
in their endeavors.
They've been to Cuba.
They've spent time there.
And it's such a cute place.
It's very pretty, and I love it.
So yeah, Media Noche
in the Mission.
JENNA TAYLOR: Favorite stories
from the home kitchens?
LIZA GERSHMAN: Gosh, so many.
JENNA TAYLOR: You're
like, so many.
LIZA GERSHMAN: So
many, so many stories.
You know, it's one of those
places where every time I go,
there's some wild
story that happens.
I'm trying to think of something
off the top of my head,
but it's just so nice to be
invited into someone's home.
And people are so generous.
Santeria is one of
the religions in Cuba,
and it's similar to
voodoo, but it's different.
Anyway, if you are walking by
anywhere and you hear drums,
you are welcome to come in
and be part of the Santeria
festivities.
And most of those
involve cakes--
many, many, many, many cakes.
And you're really encouraged to
participate and dance and sing
and eat, and you don't have to
be a practitioner of Santeria,
but it's just part
of their culture.
And it's expected that they
will invite in visitors.
And so that is a really neat
way to be able to see inside
of people's lives and homes.
And people will
shout down to you.
You'll hear drumming,
and you'll be walking by.
And somebody will be
out in the balcony,
and they'll shout down.
And they'll be saying,
come up, come up, come up.
And then you come up,
and suddenly you're
in a room that is a
quarter of this size.
And there are 20 people that are
dancing, and there's drumming.
And there are like 40
cakes on the table.
So that is one of my favorite
things about home cooked
Cuban food, absolutely.
It's pretty neat.
JENNA TAYLOR: Super powerful.
I love that visual.
Thank you so much for coming.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Thank
you for having me.
JENNA TAYLOR: Everybody, on
behalf of Google, thank you.
LIZA GERSHMAN: Thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]